Harvey Weinstein could face criminal
charges over alleged sexual assaults
investigators in New York and London are
reviewing complaints related to the
disgraced movie mogul the list of his
public accusers is growing at least 35
women have now described inappropriate
conduct by Weinstein to more women came
forward yesterday with allegations of
sexual assault now former actors Tommy
and Roberts is sharing her story of
Weinstein's alleged coercion
Jericka Duncan shows us how the incident
changed this woman's life didn't want to
join them good morning women from around
the globe have recalled traumatizing
encounters with Harvey Weinstein the
film producer has unequivocally denied
any allegations of non-consensual
consensual sex one of his accusers
recalls a life altering experience that
happened when she was just 20 years old
he was in a bathtub he tried to coerce
me to take my top off Tommy Ann Roberts
says she quit acting after being
sexually harassed by Harvey Weinstein in
1984 whose phone number do you dial at
The Weinstein Company to say this
happened to me and who on the other end
would believe me
Erika Rosenbaum told the CBC nearly 15
years ago
Weinstein grabbed her by the neck while
he pleasured himself after he talked me
into the bathroom at a Toronto hotel I
was afraid of him kate beckinsale said
when she was 17 he opened the door in
his bathrobe a few years later he asked
me if he had tried anything with me I
realized he couldn't remember if he had
assaulted me or not
it's the entitlement of too many men and
it is epidemic and when they're famous
and and powerful like Harvey then it
gets talked about Jane Fonda says she
regrets not speaking up sooner after
Rosanna Arquette revealed to her an
inappropriate encounter with Weinstein
in a 2014 interview Howard Stern asked
Weinstein about using his power to get
close to actresses did you ever get to
experience the I'm gonna say the Mogul
aspect you've never got any of them
Howard as you know only too well it
doesn't work that
it doesn't you know I'll tell you who it
works that way for it works away for the
actors don't tell me it doesn't power I
wish it I wish the movies are too
expensive the risks are too great
Weinstein is losing another source of
income he had what is called an imprint
at her shed Book Group which announced
yesterday they are shutting down
Weinstein books so I mean a lot of
people pulling out they want to distance
themselves from The Weinstein Company
and many more women feeling like this is
the time to come forward whether they've
been dealing with this for years they're
speaking out now great reporting Rika
thank you so much